in Florida well governor Rhonda Santos
he took very aggressive steps right away
what to shield Florida's very high
percentage of retirement communities and
nursing homes from the virus including
the villages America's friendliest
hometown that included targeted testing
a massive distribution of PPE strict
isolation at-risk communities and the
results they speak for themselves the
fatality rate at Florida long-term
nursing care facilities was drastically
lower than New York
it was 1.2 percent New York 18 percent
now the state has a plan to safely
reopen for business and let Floridians
back off get back on their feet here
with more Florida Governor Ron de Santos
you know it was very interesting because
I was watching the media coverage you
addressed this in DC today I was
watching the predictions for Florida
which didn't surprise me because of the
the high percentage of your population
being the elderly were off the charts
they attacked you every step of the way
you wanted to keep beaches open with
social distancing because get people out
fresh air lift their spirits etc etc
look at your number on that graph right
there and look at New York by the way
the third one in I believe is Michigan
Michigan okay you can argue doesn't have
the dense population in New York why how
did you do it because we need to learn
as we reopen well thanks John we really
focused because we knew where the threat
was and we knew where the
vulnerabilities were and so when you're
talking about putting out seven million
masks and gloves and face shields making
sure that we have teams going there to
try to see where the infections are
coming from try to work on keeping those
at bay sending National Guard units in
to do spot testing in those facilities
that is all a recognition that if the
virus gets into those facilities it can
run rampant and so we've worked really
hard to do that I got a great secretary
for health care administration Mary
Mayhew which is really spearheaded she
was fighting the whole time
she wouldn't let a hospital put
SiC Ovid patient back in a nursing home
she said you guys got to keep these
folks because then they'll infect the
rest of the nursing home so it's a very
difficult problem but I think because we
were proactive we've had much better
results at a much lower death rate than
we otherwise would
I had the head of the IDF in Israel on
my radio show about 16,000 coronavirus
people contracting the grown of our very
low death rate nobody in the military
not one death
now that we they track people in terms
of their location with their phones and
intensive contact tracing government
involvement there might be civil
liberties constitutional issues but it
worked and I want to look at every place
like Florida where things work
dramatically better as we now reopen the
country New York has special challenges
I think 50% of the work place can work
from home I think you could put people
in respirators or masks and gloves in
the workplace you'll have half the
people home so you'll have social
distancing as you open and I think
stadiums can open are you thinking about
opening up for MLB NFL maybe even NBA
well certainly we want to get there I'm
not going to promise that I'll announce
that tomorrow but I think here's they
think Shawn we know who the vulnerable
populations are we know if you look at
the statistics for people under 50 who
don't have chronic conditions I mean you
have an extremely low chance of death
from this virus in those situations and
we know how to protect folks and social
distance between those two groups and so
I think there's a lot of things we've
learned over the last six weeks so I
think we can take a step forward here in
may continue to build on that and get
America back you know I was thinking
just things in life that we take for
granted you've been doing this everyday
I've been working as governor every day
but just think of all the parents their
kids aren't in school little leagues not
going on they don't know they're not
gonna have a prom they don't have all
these things that we've taken for
granted I think people want some hope I
think people want some optimism and I
think we're at the place where this has
been tough but we have a chance to
really get to the light at the end of
the tunnel so that's what we're gonna be
trying to do in Florida
over the next many weeks I'll go through
a temperature check I'll go so I'll wear
a mask if I can go to a baseball game
I'll do whatever it takes to protect I'm
pretty healthy to protect everybody else
how much longer are you going to keep me
out of your state I would like to go
visit my second World Record Shawn
whatever I'll out back in you can you
you can come but we're gonna self
isolate you for 14 days because that
Porter you know what we would do show
does that end if you get you agree to
move your show to Naples I will do a an
Abbott Labs test for you let you run
loose and we'll let you broadcast for my
guys I I will get tested I will make
sure I'm safe but more importantly will
there be an opening for people outside
of Florida to get back in without the 14
days soon or no yeah yeah yeah we're
gonna work on that I mean obviously New
York's a special case we don't want to
see it any more infections but we're
gonna work on it either way I don't
blame you they're gonna bring their dumb
politics with them it's not good for the
state of Florida but you did a great job
you saved a lot of lives and there's a
lot to learn from your success thank you
for what you did for the great people of
the villages and every other community
down there